it's one of the most popular tourist
spots in Pakistan thousands visit the
Swat river every year that visitors
often misjudged the depth of the rapidly
moving water and children swim in the
current oblivious of the dangers
hundreds of people have drowned over the
years because there are no lifeguards
and only one River Rescue Service
Mohammed Helen is the man to call when
someone falls in or gets swept away but
first he has to weave through traffic
the glacial melt during summer months is
so strong it even sweeps away vehicles
illegal sand mining has left deep
ditches in the riverbed and acts like
quicksand if someone gets stuck
Hilal uses bamboo sticks and rubber
tubes as a DIY rescue raft in these
Rapids for about a hundred kilometres
this is the only rescue service most of
the time he'll I'll only find bodies he
took over from his father and has been a
volunteer for the last 30 years I found
more than 300 people who drowned in this
river my numbers on social media and
with the police in case there's a
drowning I take my raft and start
searching sometimes I'm lucky and find
the person within the hours but
sometimes it takes me days bacha is
grateful to halal for finding the body
of his brother who drowned but is angry
at the government there was no help from
the government Rescue Services they were
incapable and didn't have any
specialized gear to operate in the river
our family isn't debted to halal who
helped us without any compensation and
recovered my brother if he wasn't
helping people no one would find their
missing loved ones some people in Swat
accused the government of corruption and
failing to provide a rescue service they
haven't provided any kind of
facilitation or safety measures in case
someone drowns the people have been
hired in the rescue service can't even
swim so how can they rescue someone the
local government admits that it needs to
take action
rescue establishments throughout the
Roberto are awareness program and
stoppage of illegal mining so
that differences should not be found in
this river these are the four five prong
strategies on which we are working to
get these incidents less and less allows
afraid he might not be able to persuade
his son to carry on the voluntary rescue
work when he retires once the government
to raise awareness and hi professionals
to save lives sama bin Javed al-jazeera
Swat River northern Pakistan